one of the things that you bring up
right at the beginning is that you say
that the grand narratives that we used
to identify with the the root cause of
this crowd arrangement to thing collapse
of all of our grand narrative yes what
why is that enabled this this broader
situation that we're seeing in front of
us because it's crosses all of that it's
enabled the gay the trans the the race
discussions so sort of visceral so my
feeling is that we look there's
something incredibly deep has happened
underneath our societies which we're in
if not in denial about we don't face up
to which is we're living at a stage
where we might be among the first people
in human history to have absolutely no
explanation for what we're doing here
and no story to tell about what we
should do other than there are
narratives they're pretty weak ones and
accumulated as much money as you can and
enjoy yourself there's one yeah
gain some Twitter followers yeah it's
not the worst idea in human history but
it's a it's a fairly shallow one as I
say I mean this this paucity of ideas I
say it's it's obviously the consequence
for the collapse of religion which is
pretty much an irreversible issue now
and the collapse of organized religion
the collapse of all major political
ideologies in the 20th century other
than in the present structure which is a
you know broadly liberal state of the
capitalist economy and I think that in
the last 10 years baiting in the wake of
the 2008 financial crash a lot of
confidence the self confidence was lost
in capitalism which is I think a
disaster in all sorts of ways because
it's you know as like Churchill fame
said up to James he said about democracy
it's the worst system apart from all of
the others and and we've so in a strange
position where we've really run out of
things to believe in and we sort of
pretend that well just find your own
meaning in the world
and that's one of the reasons why as I
say I mean I think that it's very
understandable that people then get
caught up in in new ideologies of this
and my view is that the social justice
movement intersectionality all this
stuff is a version of it so it's a way
to give life meaning and the problem
with it among other things is that all
of these things equal what rights for
women equal rights for sexual minorities
equal rights for racial minorities and
so on are very good things and they are
the products of liberal rights but we've
tried to instead of being the products
of them it's like we've flipped the
whole barstool around and trying to sit
on the products of the right and it it
doesn't support itself because as I as I
show in each chapter each of these not
only are each of these things gay
relations mean sexes race and trans not
only are they going against each other
in very interesting ways trans against
women trans against gay and so on but
but they each in themselves are more
unstable than we're willing to admit so
for instance we still don't know very
much about being gay we don't know quite
what causes it and there's been a study
that's just come out since my book came
out which sort of indicates what I say
which is it's a bit more it's a bit more
complex than we've we pretend relations
between sexes and our attitudes as a
society towards women in particular a
very contradictory and we pretend
they're not so we pretend that women are
simultaneously exactly the same as men
and magically better on occasion we just
decided to hold that idea and with race
we are very very unsure for good reasons
for good reasons because who wants to
open that up really well a lot of people
it turns out but I explain why I think
that's gonna be risky and then you have
the trans one and that's just really
really uncertain and really really not
something we know enough about or so not
as much as we're pretending and and so
I'm just was saying let's lean
all of these things a little less let's
not make everything about these identity
issues let's let's try not to lean as
much as we are on them and try to get
back to what I thought was the aim which
was equal not better equal and focusing
on the content of people's character
[Music]
you